we're in Whistler riding with a fastest
man at poor knobby tires Stacy Kohut
Stacy is awesome he's flying down the
hill yes Stacy's home hack quad bike is
reaching speeds of up to 60 miles per
hour I would actually love to try this
not the bike going down the cable car
going up view is spectacular we travel
to Vancouver Canada to meet this
downhill daredevil riding the four-wheel
mountain bike for me is like Christmas
my birthday Easter Valentine's Day and
summer break all rolled into one I've
dedicated everything to this bike and
doing what I do the thing that I love
the most about four-wheel mountain
biking is that there's two sides there's
the sawfish part which is wind in the
face showing off for the girls being
super flashy in rock and roll I love
that the other part of what I do let's
be honest it's a hardcore social
statement
it's me saying you know what I'm in a
wheelchair I can do whatever I want
look at me go out there and kick some
butt this is a pure extension of me if I
can inspire young kids to be themselves
then I've done my job so how does Stacy
conquer the track
stacy is using a four wheel bike to pull
this off this 4-week bike has a much
lower center of mass making it
inherently more stable another advantage
of 4 wheels is that stacy has more grip
on the road so this means he can take
corners at higher speeds what's
incredible about these four wheel bike
is that it has no pedals so he needs to
use gravity to go down if you make a
mistake you can't quickly pedal back up
to speed so you got to be really smart
in your line choice and when you're
braking and when you're not braking to
complete the course
stacy has to make his way over several
jumps and so to do this stacy preloads
his suspension and what this means is
that he pushes weight down and some of
that energy goes into elastic energy in
the suspension and just as he goes over
the jump he releases that elastic energy
and he gets some serious airtime it's
fun to go out there and and put on that
show and be that example because the
kids are getting it and sometimes I
think that's all that really matters as
long as the kids get it because they're
the ones they're gonna form the next
generation of opinions about people with
disabilities